Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When watching science fiction movies, we often
encounter crazy devices and technologies that
don’t really exist, or sometimes, ones that
are not even possible to make.
For instance, reconstructing sound from vibrations
would be an excellent example of that, and
could make a great novel with the secret service
trying to catch dangerous criminals.
Except that it has already been done in real
life research.
I think you can imagine how surprised I was
when I saw this paper in 2014 that showcased
a result where a camera looks at this bag
of chips, and from these tiny-tiny vibrations,
it could reconstruct the sounds in the room.
Let’s listen.
Yes, this indeed sounds like science fiction.
But 2014 was a long-long time ago, and since
then, we have a selection of powerful learning
algorithms, and the question is, what’s
the next idea that sounded completely impossible
a few years ago, which is now possible?
Well, what about looking at silent footage
from a speaker and trying to guess what they
were saying?
Checkmark, that sounds absolutely impossible
to me, yet, this new technique is able to
produce the entirety of this speech after
looking at the video footage of the lip movements.
Let’s listen.
Wow.
So the first question is, of course, what
was used as the training data?
It used a dataset with lecture videos and
chess commentary from 5 speakers, and make
no mistake, it takes a ton of data from these
speakers, about 20 hours from each, but it
uses video that was shot in a natural setting,
which is something that we have in abundance
on Youtube and other places on the internet.
Note that the neural network works on the
same speakers it was trained on and was able
to learn their gestures and lip movements
remarkably well.
However, this is not the first work attempting
to do this, so let’s see how it compares
to the competition.
The new one is very close to the true spoken
sentence.
Let’s look at another one.
Note that there are gestures, a reasonable
amount of head movement and other factors
at play and the algorithm does amazingly well.
Potential applications of this could be video
conferencing in zones where we have to be
silent, giving a voice to people with the
inability to speak due to aphonia or other
conditions, or, potentially fixing a piece
of video footage where parts of the speech
signal are corrupted.
In these cases, the gaps could be filled in
with such
a technique.
Look!
Now, let’s have a look under the hood.
If we visualize the activations within this
neural network, we see that it found out that
it mainly looks at the mouth of the speaker.
That is, of course, not surprising.
However, what is surprising is that the other
regions, for instance, around the forehead
and eyebrows are also important to the attention
mechanism.
Perhaps this could mean that it also looks
at the gestures of the speaker, and uses that
information for the speech synthesis.
I find this aspect of the work very intriguing
and would love to see some additional analysis
on that.
There is so much more in the paper, for instance,
I mentioned giving a voice to people with
aphonia, which should not be possible because
we are training these neural networks for
a specific speaker, but with an additional
speaker embedding step, it is possible to
pair up any speaker with any voice.
This is another amazing work that makes me
feel like we are living in a science fiction
world.
I can only imagine what we will be able to
do with this technique two more papers down
the line.
If you have any ideas, feel free to speculate
in the comments section below.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!